[MUSIC PLAYING]
There are a few
questions that come
to mind when I hear about
In-App Payment House Ads.
One, how can we improve
our monetization strategy?
Two, can we do it and keep
a smile on our users' faces?
Three, how to serve the
right ad to the right user.
Four, what is the best
beverage for the winter?
All are valid problems.
Today, we're going to focus
on solving the first three.
Cool?
You've got mountains
and mountains of data.
Data that could change
your business, so much
data that it's overwhelming
and perhaps easier to ignore.
But that's the
wrong thing to do.
You don't want to
be like that dragon
sitting on a hoard of gold
but doing nothing with it.
You wish to use a
monetization platform that
saves you leg works.
We call it "audience aware."
It will automatically
predict likely spenders.
In-App Payment House Ads help
you grow your overall revenue
and create new revenue streams.
Imagine an app were only 3%
of the users make purchases.
Those 3% are loyal and engaged.
There may be items
in your game that
will help them progress
to the next level.
But they don't know about it.
You can create an
In-App Payment House Ads
and promote a particular
items to them.
The smart thing is that
AdMob uses Google algorithms
and machine learning to
only show those ads to users
who are likely to buy.
The good part is this for
the other 97% of users
who won't make any purchase,
you could show a regular ad,
creating a new incremental
revenue stream for your game.
Let's have a look
at the case study.
We ran two experiments.
On the first case, we
showed an arbitrary sample
of users an In-House
Payment offer wall.
In our second experiment, we
showed the same offer wall,
but this time only
showed it to users
that our algorithms predicted
that would be a spender.
As you can see, the
results were great.
What gets me excited
is what we could
do we do out there
139,000 of persons
that weren't exposed to the
In-App Payments offer wall.
By leveraging AdMob,
ads would predict
a revenue increase or five
times over the first case.
[CHEERING]
So this is the way to improve
your monetization strategy
and keep a smile on your users.
We use In-App Payment
House Ads in order
to serve the right ad
to the right users.
On our next episode,
we will see how
to get more users to your app.
Cool?
Until next time,
eat your vegetables,
create cool In-App Payments,
and listen to your partners.
[MUSIC PLAYING]